Mexico is expected to deploy up to 6000
National Guard members to it's Guatemala
border soon as thousands of Central
American migrants try to reach the
us-mexico agreed to tighten the border
after President Trump threatened to
impose tariffs and well Bojorquez is in
Hidalgo Mexico where a river runs along
the border Manny what's the mission
there well Anthony the Trump
administration is hoping that if Mexican
authorities can reduce the flow of
Central American migrants here along the
border with Guatemala that would bring
down the number of apprehensions along
the border with the US where the numbers
have been surging but this here is a
porous border you can see Guatemala on
the other side this is the SOOC out the
river and people here traditionally just
pay somebody on a raft like this one
here to come across now Mexico has
indicated it would deploy its National
Guard troops along 11 municipalities
that provide key routes for asylum
seekers but as of this morning we
haven't yet seen a large deployment in
this area there is however a lingering
fear among locals about potential
clashes between the guard and the
hundreds who use this unofficial border
crossing every day we should point out
that other Mexican agencies have already
been working on cracking down we saw
immigration authorities pull this family
from a van Monday after they were not
able to present the proper documents the
big question here of course is if these
migrants who are fleeing violence and
poverty will reconsider their plans to
try to seek asylum in the United States
in light of the crackdown we spoke with
one person who said she would reconsider
and might stay in Mexico but another one
said as far as getting to the US where
there is a will there is a way
gaile Oh is the case but Manning before
you go how will officials judge whether
this plan is working well the u.s. and
Mexico have essentially said they would
look at this again in 90 days and if the
number of migrants hasn't dropped
significantly they could go back to the
renegotiating table the US could try to
push another demand out of Mexico when
Mexico has not agreed to yet and that is
for this country here to become what's
called a safe third
meaning that anyone coming here seeking
asylum would have to claim asylum in
Mexico first right men will work is
reporting thank you very much